foreign
this is a headline that just tickled me
angry Morgan Wallen fan sends the singer
a four thousand dollar bill for a
canceled show
so if you don't know Morgan Wallen is a
is a big country singer out there what's
one of his songs I couldn't tell you
Jade I don't listen to that okay okay I
just want to check because I don't know
who the heck this is I don't know but
he's a big country okay he was on The
Voice or something like season six which
again I don't watch that show so this
woman though so Morgan Wallen everyone's
sitting there at the concert and on the
screen appears this message saying
Morgan Wallen has lost his voice he can
no longer perform get your refunds at
point of purchase oh so everyone who has
traveled to this concert paid all this
money is now very upset because they
only get the ticket price they get the
ticket price back and so one woman named
Mandy who attended the concert posted on
Facebook and tagged the singer with her
Express wish to pay for everything from
their outfits to gas and so she said
since you're offering refunds here's our
itemized bill for you and she listed out
on her Facebook post whoa the expenses
we'll put it on the screen if you're
watching on YouTube Hotel 560 makes
sense okay okay tracking so far gas two
tanks 80 bucks okay Hotel gas okay four
tickets 1600 bucks who's paying 400 to
see Morgan Wallen I truthfully don't
know I don't know because I've never
heard of them that's some Taylor Swift
money okay 400 my outfit 120 bucks
husband's outfit 218 dollars Oxford
Grill House 235 is that a restaurant
Cracker Barrel forty dollars
perleros 45
Rebel Rags I don't know what that is but
I don't want anything I think because
they wouldn't have the opportunity to go
had it not been for the concert 629
drinks at the concert before it started
by the way 220 Morgan Wallen merch 235
whoa grand total Jade
3982 dollars I gotta take my shirt off I
gotta take my jacket off y'all can you
imagine
billing an artist for four thousand
dollars for your own stupidity
and she put her cash app right there in
the post going I'll expect my refund
tomorrow thanks bro thanks bro yeah and
she ended it with some there's some
expletives in there it's a
family-friendly show but she said my
husband has gone with me to two concerts
ever in the 17 years we've been together
somehow I talked him into this one and
this happens well she's got so what do
you think is she entitled to a refund
for all of the other expenses outside of
her ticket
um
no she's got Moxie she's got some grit
there I'll give I'll give her that but
here's the thing
um
yes it would be nice if they gave a
little bit more than the ticket price
here's as a vocalist I can say sometimes
you just get laryngitis many times I've
had to cancel two shows of my own
volition in my life and I hated every
moment and one of it because I had
laryngitis and everybody got back their
ticket price but I just want to know and
can you guys put in the comments
wherever you're watching do you buy new
outfits for a concert I didn't know this
was a thing do you buy a whole new
outfit now she's not on stage no one's
looking at what she's wearing but she
wants to feel cute okay and all that
beating Walden didn't tell him that they
had to go to Roadhouse or Texas Grill or
wherever they went the most hilarious
part is the cheapest expense on this
whole list is Cracker Barrel so well
represent Cracker Barrel beating
inflation out there they're like we
gonna get our dumplings we're gonna make
sure we get our chicken and dumpling you
know I'm looking at it like you paid for
a trip that you weren't expecting to
take yeah
you know and you missed out on the
concert ticket price back which she's
getting her ticket price back so 1600
bucks is back so I think it's unfair to
say that she's getting she needs four
grand back she's already getting the
1600 back yeah I'm not mad at that look
it took spunk for her to to step to
Morgan Wallen like that but I'm glad
that she did it took spunk to admit all
of that spending happened within a
24-hour period I don't think I would be
able to spend three grand in 24 hours no
me neither I want to know her budget and
the fact that she called him bro at the
end is it's pretty simple broch at the
concert I mean what are y'all getting
are they charging like 19 for Bud Light
these days they're turning up oh gosh
that's a lot for me so here's the here's
the teaching out of this if there is one
teach it uh posting on Facebook maybe
won't solve anything here's the my
question is are people now going to send
her money to her cash app as kind of a
joke and she's now gonna make like 20
grand this is going to be a GoFundMe
moment
so there's one wow but number two budget
for your trips and concerts and don't
spend willy-nilly like if you're on a
budget and you spent that that's fine
clearly they were just spending
willy-nilly probably putting this on
credit cards that's right and here's
another teaching point because this
reminds me of the folks who were taking
out 401K loans to go see Beyonce I heard
about that this you can't do this we
can't spend three thousand dollars you
want to spend that kind of money to see
Queen B you're gonna be you're gonna be
broke you're going to be broke good job
George